cuando estudiamos a las células digamos
debido a la visualización que tenemos en
un libro de texto o incluso en algunas
micrografías podríamos imaginar a las
células como como estos pequeños globos
verdad que que tienen mucho fluido
dentro verdad y que tienen otras cosas
que están flotando dentro de estos
globos verdad y de hecho aquí tenemos
una imagen de una célula verdad de esto
es una sección transversal de la célula
y aquí podemos ver varias partes
importantes de ella verdad aquí por
ejemplo tenemos el núcleo tenemos el
retículo endoplasmático tenemos el
aparato de golgi también tenemos un par
de de mitocondrias verdad y podríamos
pensar que todas todas estas estructuras
están flotando en el sito sol verdad y
hasta cierto punto es cierto verdad hay
mucha agua en las células pero también
resulta que a todos estos dibujos les
hace falta un aspecto crucial de las
células verdad pues les hace falta
si tu esqueleto el cit o esqueleto y lo
he escrito con dos colores distintos a
propósito verdad porque justamente el
citoesqueleto significa el esqueleto de
la célula y de hecho algo muy fascinante
de del citoesqueleto es que aún tratamos
de entender cómo es que funciona cómo es
que se mueve cómo es que da forma a las
células verdad así que el citoesqueleto
se puede ver como una colección muy
grande de estructuras que que parecen
como una especie no sé de quizás como de
hilos que están atravesando de distintas
formas y por distintas partes a las
células y es como podríamos ir pensando
a grosso a grosso modo al citoesqueleto
verdad y estas estructuras se mueven
crecen y digamos también ayudan a la
célula a poder moverse ya poder
transportar algunas cosas de hecho para
ayudar a entender cómo es que se ve el
citoesqueleto
esta imagen que tengo del lado izquierdo
que nos ayudará a entender la
complejidad que hay en una sola de tus
células por ejemplo verdad así que
fijémonos en algunas de las estructuras
que tenemos por aquí verdad tenemos por
ejemplo esta estructura esta estructura
de aquí de hecho tiene un nombre muy
particular a esta estructura que tenemos
aquí la conocemos como micro filamentos
es un micro filamento muy bien este
micro filamento tiene en realidad es
sumamente delgado verdad este tiene un
digamos un espesor de aproximadamente 6
a 7 nanómetros recordemos que un
nanómetro verdad es una milésima parte
de un milímetro verdad y de hecho se
tiene estimado que el diámetro de una
célula es de aproximadamente 6 a 7
milímetros así que estamos diciendo que
el digamos el espesor o el ancho de este
micro filamento verdad es de
aproximadamente una milésima parte del
diámetro de esta célula así que quizás
pinte estos estos micro filamentos muy
muy gruesos en comparación de cómo
deberían verse verdad y ahí tienes una
idea de por qué casi nunca se pintan en
este tipo de visualizaciones pero bueno
estos micro filamentos tienen una
dinámica tienen dinámica porque pueden
ser creados pueden destruirse pueden
cambiar su longitud y por ejemplo
también pueden transportar cosas verdad
de hecho estos micro filamentos están
hechos de algo que llamamos actina
verdad están hechos de actina ok están
hechos de actina y que de hecho puedes
pensar los como como si fueran cuerdas
amarradas verdad aquí más o menos se ven
estas dos estas dos con digamos como
estos dos hilos que se amarran o se
entrelazan verdad
entonces como ya mencioné esto le da le
da estructura y movimiento a la célula
muy bien de hecho hay una interacción
fascinante entre la actina y estas
estructuras que vemos por ejemplo aquí
para dar estas estructuras que vemos
aquí que están hechas de miosina verdad
estas de aquí están hechas de míos y na
gates es mío
china ok y este tipo de interacción que
hay entre la miosina y la actina verdad
la relación que hay entre estas dos es
que por alguna razón se mantienen cerca
y de hecho estas estructuras se mueven
relativamente respecto a la otra verdad
y esto es esencial por ejemplo para la
contracción de músculos de hecho es
fascinante ver que cosas como como las
proteínas verdad porque estamos hablando
de un nivel de proteínas es es
fascinante ver que este tipo de cosas
que son sólo un montón de aminoácidos
pueden interactuar en estas formas tan
complejas muy bien ahora otra cosa que
podemos observar por ejemplo por ejemplo
aquí verdad esta estructura que tenemos
aquí esto es un ribosoma libre esto es
que no es un ribosoma que esté atado al
retículo endoplasmático así que podemos
ver que toda esta estructura es
increíblemente compleja verdad podemos
observar otros microfilamentos por aquí
verdad podemos ver
un micro filamento aquí podemos ver otro
micro filamento
por acá abajo aquí podemos ver otro otro
pedacito de ribosoma otro pedazo de
ribosoma y si eres muy muy observador
podrás distinguir esta estructura gruesa
verdad esta estructura gruesa que
tenemos aquí que tiene como como forma
de tubo verdad así que uno podría
preguntarse bueno y qué es esto y de
hecho estos tienen un nombre justamente
de lo que parecen y se les conoce como
microtúbulos estos son microtúbulos
verdad y de hecho en esta imagen por
ejemplo se ven masivos pero en realidad
no lo son tanto en digamos en una escala
celular son sumamente pequeños también
por ejemplo tienen
un ancho de 25 nanómetros nada más
son sumamente delgados también y son
fundamentales en la digamos para dar la
estructura de la célula verdad permite
que las cosas se organicen y sean
transportadas verdad también son
estructuras dinámicas pueden destruirse
crear se pueden cambiar de forma pueden
ayudarle a la célula a cambiar de forma
verdad así que todo lo que he descrito
hasta aquí se halla en la mayor parte de
las células verdad pero en células
animales por ejemplo también hallarás
cosas llamadas filamentos intermedios
que justamente tiene un tamaño
intermedio entre estos dos verdad entre
el micro filamento y los microtúbulos y
también ayudan a mantener la forma así
que el punto central de este vídeo es
simplemente darte una mejor idea de qué
tan bellas y complejas son las cosas que
quizás podríamos pensar regularmente que
son simples verdad como una célula
y que en ocasiones no aparecerá por
ejemplo en los en los dibujos de los
libros de texto y para tener una mejor
apreciación verdad de todo esto traigo
aquí unas cuantas imágenes estas son
imágenes de algunas células verdad en
donde el citoesqueleto está coloreado
por ejemplo la la la imagen que tenemos
aquí del lado izquierdo verdad muestra
justamente estos es de esta especie como
de de hilos verdad esta es una imagen de
una célula de pulmón de vaca o son
varias células de pulmón de vaca y esto
que se ve como en un amarillo verdoso
son justamente los microtúbulos mientras
que lo que se ve al fondo más o menos
como de color naranja son los
microfilamentos así que aquí se ve mucho
mejor la complejidad y la estructura de
todo esto que podrías pensar que
simplemente eran unas gotas